[Music]
right microwave or as you well know to
you and i microwave or as every chef in
the country knows chef mike whatever you
call it sometimes i promise you it can
be helpful
on certain occasions this is the ramsey
classic it is a beautiful sticky toffee
pudding and i promise you
it's done in 10 minutes
with my amazing assistant who never
answers back chef mike right oscar pan
down let me show you so the big secret
behind any
stickers i'm putting are dates we're
gonna slice them up mix them a little
bit bicarb that's gonna literally cause
a bit of reaction it'll start to puree
those dates then i'm gonna make the cake
mix with beautiful brown sugar butter
flour egg and this baby here golden
syrup we all grew up with that so
delicious then on to the sauce finish
with a nice tart
creme fresh right let's get 10 minutes
on the chef mike
right power up to 100 okay for 30
seconds no you're not going to believe
me this is actually going to be done in
the microwave it's a beautiful fast
track sticky toffee pudding here we go
dates
now come on we all have a date unless
you're my assistant justin mandel hasn't
had one in four years but these are soft
chewy delicious and more importantly
i'm hoping after this lockdown that he
does have a date and she decides to stay
with him but
now dates slice them nice and thinly
okay
once they're sliced nice and thinly
just put them into a bowl okay
and then from there literally
a little teaspoon of bicarb okay now
this literally helps to break down
the dates okay a little touch of water
in there
just a touch
and that will start
almost pureeing the dates
chef mike are you ready
here we go right
on
power 100
and let's go for 30 seconds
and go
now
let's start the actual cake mix okay
let's get the butter in
okay
alongside the brown sugar now start to
cream that okay best thing to do is get
the back of the wooden spoon and just
literally
lightly beat that
and what happens now is that we start to
sort of break down the butter
and we form this really nice sort of
batter
how long left
eight minutes
now
from there
cream with the back of your spoon
okay
literally sometimes i put my hand on the
bottom of the bowl and the heat from my
hands starts to melt the butter nicely
and then look
mix that up
nice
once we start to cream that
in
that butter starts to melt
and the sugar starts to disintegrate
in with a nice
tablespoon
of this beautiful syrup
now
in
and over twist that around back up
don't spoil any
beautiful
now from there
use that spoon to clean that off
okay
and then literally
start creaming that up
now
it may sound a little bit
bizarre using chef mike but trust me
every chef uses them and sometimes
they're just great
for reheating dishes
and as you know a microwave cooked from
the inside
so you have to be very careful
egg
flat surface crack lift up
and beat that in now
now you can start to see this batter
sort of forming
but use the spatula clean the spoon and
clean the sides as you go along
and then flip over
now once you start
using the spatula
we're incorporating a bit of air now
and that's going to make the mixture
a little
lighter
good
time please
six minutes
great
now
if it starts to separate kind of a
little whisk
and just
give that a really nice whisk
and that will get your batter really
nice and smooth
okay
and here we go
chef mike to the redmi
now once that's nice and smooth
it should look a little granular like
that
nothing wrong with that from there get
your dates
okay
and look they've broken down
a touch okay
they've gone literally almost like a
nice cure
back in there for another
30 seconds
here we go
and that starts to break those dates
down now
butter sugar syrup are in
okay
and then from there
give it a really good whisk
they're nice and smooth
and now look
just
on now
from there dates out
you can see what's happened there look
at this nice beautiful
date puree in goes
the days
beautiful
in goes
the flour okay we're gonna sift that in
there make sure there's no additional
lumps
and this is where it goes up a notch
okay normally we'd be steaming these and
baking them in the oven
with paper on top and sort of steaming
them for 45-50 minutes it's a really
nice fast track
way
now whisk comes out
give that whisk a nice shake
and then just a couple of turns
the whisk comes out
get the spatula in there we get that
nice even distribution of that flour
through that mix
so now it's looking like a really nice
delicious
batter
right bowl
make sure it's nice and dry
brush generously with your butter okay
and then just lightly
vertically put those strokes up that
will help the sticky toffee pudding
coming out and it is just a light
smidging of butter
from there
almost like a sort of
half a tablespoon of flour
shake that around
and then just line that mould
and all that does it stops it from
sticking once you've gone all the way
around
back in
and then look get your mixture
and fill it two thirds full
and now this is where the magic starts
back on two thirds full
just in there
now
give that a gentle tap
that let's mix it all the way
around the bottom and now
take some kitchen roll
okay and just sit that on top
i want to go sort of 30 seconds times
four
into chef mike the paper helps it steam
to begin with then halfway through it
will take the paper off chef mike
work your magic myself work your magic
in
now set that to 30 seconds 30 second
increments right
chef mike work your magic right
pan on
now for the beautiful
campbell sauce
so that paper helps to steam the top
and it should be about two and a half to
three minutes in chef mike's oven
first
in goes
your butter okay
now i'm gonna make this beautiful
caramel sauce melt that butter
sugar goes in
and now we're going to start a camel 30
more seconds
there we go
now melt
melt your sugar
so for the beautiful sauce i've got
brown sugar butter
in there i've got some double cream and
then to finish
the top i'm going to put some creme
fraiche on top of that pudding
bring that to a boil and add a
tablespoon of that beautiful golden
syrup
chef mike is working his magic time
please
now stir that sugar
let's check on chef mike
now
look where we are
take that off
and that is getting there
okay
beautiful now
chef mike does tend to be a little bit
dirty
okay so like all good chefs
work nice and tidy
look at that it's started already
take
the paper off back in
chef mike
it's on overtime today
now sauce
look at that melt the sugar the butter
syrup in
and then fold in your cream
that's going to make a beautiful
amazing
caramel sauce
melt that syrup
chef pike
and then add
your cream in there now
cream goes in
that stops the sugar
from burning back onto the stove
and look at that it's got this beautiful
aerated toffee
beautiful syrupy sauce
and
mix that in
off
i want that really nice
beautiful syrupy lovely toffee sauce
time please how long one minute come on
man come on chef mike
monty
right um
that smells good
that smells really good get a little
knife and just go around the outside
and then on
one
two
three drop
you ready
oh yeah beauty
and then you get your sauce
and you just coat that
and hit it on top so it sort of falls
over we call it nape
and it's just like this perfect
beautiful mound of
sticky toffee pudding
and then look
you got your creme fraiche
your sticky toffee pudding and just to
be ultra chefy get some
toffee on that creme fraiche
and there you go a beautiful sticky top
of pudding in 10 minutes thanks to chef
mike
to all of you thank you for watching
ramsay intend if i went too quick i
apologize but slow it down now don't
forget to pick up ramsey intent cookbook
inspired by this series and trust me
you're going to come out a much better
chef and if you like this video don't
forget to subscribe to my amazing
youtube channel for more good luck